هذا النجار علي بابا *** دوما يتجول في الغابة
يجمع أخشابا كي يصنع *** نافذة منها أو بابا
يوما في الغابة يتمشى***  لمح لصوصا قرب مغارة
فاختبأ وجلس يراقبهم *** شاهد ما فعلوا فاحتار
قالوا افتح يا سمسم
بقي علي بابا مذهول  ***  ابتعدت عن بابها صخرة  ***  وسيدهم يأمر بدخول
لبثو قليلا بعدها خرجوا ***   و قالوا اغلق يا سمسم
ثم انصرفوا وعلي بابا ***   بدخولها أصبح مهتم
علي بابا  لا لا لا لا  *** علي بابا  لا لا لا لا
كرر ما فعلوا علي بابا *** دخل وفيها وجد العجب
ذهبا وكنوزا أموالا *** عبأ كيسه ثم انسحب
عاد لزوجته مسرورا ***  قال سنعطي للفقراء
وللناس نعيد أمانتهم ***  ونصير جميعا سعداء
رجع الأشرار إلى الكهف ***   ولم يجدوا جل الأموال
وهنالك قد فهموا الدرس ***   لن يفلح أبدا محتال
علي بابا  لا لا لا لا  *** علي بابا  لا لا لا لا